e aí
e como essa música tem sabor de infância
ela marcou a minha vida a minha história
eu era criança quando eu ouvi a primeira
vez do ano de 1983 a propaganda passava
na tv em preto e branco e eu brincava no
quintal com a minha irmã mais nova
quando eu vi essa música ela me chamou
atenção eu corri para a sala de casa
hoje só para passar na propaganda de uma
caixa de lápis de cor um caderno e
vários sonhos que eu via naquelas
imagens e de repente eu comecei a sonhar
a me imaginar tendo aquela caixa de
lápis de cor e aquele caderno essa
música do autor toquinho chamada
aquarela quem aqui é pai ou mãe levanta
o braço por gentileza
é muito bem provavelmente quando o teu
filho pede alguma coisa você se esforça
para dar aquilo que ele precisa aquilo
que ele deseja comigo não foi diferente
eu também tinha sonhos mas aquela
ocasião eu meus pais não tinham
condições de lhe dar aquela caixa de
lápis de cor da propaganda e nem o
caderno
e quando eu era criança lá em irituia eu
era uma criança assim e assado eu era
uma criança feliz e minha mãe contava
ela me contou quando ela estava grávida
de mim eles moravam numa cidade chamada
mãe do rio uma cidade pequena mas dessa
cidade ela não tinha estrutura para que
ela me concedesse então ela é meu pai
foram para a cidade mais próxima chamada
irituia e latinha cartório hospital
realmente que pudesse dar uma vida mais
digna na hora do parto então assim eu
nasci nessa cidade foi registrado após
meus pais começaram a enfrentar algumas
dificuldades algumas turbulências
financeiras naquela cidade e eles
escolheram uma terceira cidade para
morar para mudar chamada castanhol fica
próximo da cidade de belém uma cidade
mais desenvolvida e foi lá que a nossa
vida começou de fato
o empreendedor e tinha uma loja de
bicicletas e minha mãe era costureira
todos os dois falavam bastante para
criar seis filhos
bom e o que é que eu efetuei show tem a
ver com a minha vida com a minha jornada
bom muito aplicado no mundo empresarial
esse conceito que é da professora saras
sarasvathy diz o seguinte o
empreendedorismo ele pode ser
desenvolvido nas pessoas embora seja um
conceito novo mas eu já tive contato com
ele muito antes na minha infância e não
sabia que realmente eu havia utilizado o
que que ele diz ele tem cinco princípios
o primeiro deles é o pássaro na mão que
diz o seguinte se você tem uma ideia
começa usa aquilo que você tem e dá o
pontapé inicial
e o segundo é defina perdas aceitáveis é
porque na vida nem todo dia a gente
ganha e muitas vezes para a gente poder
conquistar ao a gente precisa abrir mão
de outras
e o terceiro é colcha de retalhos ou
crença por meio de parcerias o quarto é
faça do limão uma limonada ou seja
explore todas as possibilidades que
estão ali ao teu redor e o quinto o
futuro é imprevisível construa o seu
seja o piloto da aeronave pois bem se um
pinguinho de tinta cai num pedacinho
azul do papel num instante imagino uma
linda gaivota a voar no céu assim foi o
meu começo o que que eu tinha para
começar
o bom era uma manhã e eu tinha que ir
para escola e de repente me veio à mente
aquela imagem da propaganda que eu vim a
caixa de lápis de cor e o caderno e eu
virei para minha mãe e pedir a minha mãe
olhou para mim e disse que ela não tinha
condições de me dar nem o caderno e nem
a caixa de lápis de cor
é mas ela tinha algo que ela ia me
oferecer ela era costureira e tinha uma
criatividade muito grande ela se dirigiu
até a máquina de costura pegou uma linho
pegou a tesoura pegou um papel kraft
esse papel aqui era muito utilizado
naquela época para embrulhar pão ela
pegou o papel a tesoura começou a cortar
como estivesse fazendo uma roupa e
cortou em diversos pedaços de papéis ela
pegou agulha e começou a fazer um
caderninho de repente ela virou para mim
e me entregou aquele caderno naquela
manhã e disse filho tá aqui e pegou um
pedaço de lápis preto e me entregou esse
olhar é isso que eu tenho para você vai
estudar
bom então eu olhei para aquele caderno
eu fiquei atônito realmente eu não sabia
de fato como eu iria reagir embora eu
fosse uma criança muito compreensiva e
não com formada mas eu entendi aqui era
uma situação passageira eu peguei aquele
caderno e aquela mulher brava aquela
mulher determinada e cheia de fé ela
fica encorajar os filhos eram seis ela
pegou e passava aquela coragem através
do olhar naquele caderno eu peguei o
caderno coloquei debaixo do braço e fui
para escola quando eu cheguei lá eu
percebi que vários dos colegas tinham
vários cadernos eram cadernos muito
bonitos eram caderno de marcas e lápis
igual da propaganda eu olhava para o meu
olhava para o deles
e o meu não era feio o meu não era o
pior meu tinha uma pitada doce de mãe se
uma marca artesanal talvez nenhum
daqueles alunos que estavam lá tinha um
caderno feito com tanto amor o meu tinha
a minha mãe fez ele para mim e foi aí
que eu comecei a entender o sentido eo
significado e o valor das coisas através
daquele caderno e eu comecei a estudar e
as e o tempo foi passando e de repente
pra encaixar o mesmo já na minha
adolescência sem pedir licença as coisas
vão acontecendo e eu já tinha aí ali 18
anos precisava trabalhar eu precisava
realmente me manter passar no vestibular
então conversando com a minha mãe eu
disse aí mãe ah eu tenho que ir sair de
castanhal porque eu tô vendo que aqui
realmente a minha sorte não está então
as pessoas antigas e ele falava sorte
e eu segui a manada não era diferente
mas eu tinha que sair dali porque eu não
tava conseguindo realmente de fato
continuar estudando gente prestar
vestibular e trabalhar ao mesmo tempo e
de repente esse que surgem aos dois
amigos naquela rua que eram carreteiros
e eles conversavam muito comigo eu tinha
muita curiosidade eu perguntar vou pegar
no mapa do brasil e começar a perguntar
para esse cara com esse dessa cidade que
tem no mapa que você que pelo fato de
você viajar tanto você me recomendaria
para que eu fosse tentar minha vida e
não dele falou o cara vai para goiânia
eu vou levar uma carga lá depois de
amanhã vou passar vou para são paulo eu
passo em goiânia te deixe
e eu decidido que eu realmente iria sair
de casa iria sair para buscar vida
melhor para estudar e trabalhar eu
voltei para minha mãe falei mãe eu eu
vou para goiânia ela olhou para mim eu
falei com muita determinação ela disse
assim filho como é que vai ser eu não
tenho condições de te manter lá eu esse
mãe não preocupa eu me viro eu faço
qualquer coisa trabalho para ter
dinheiro ela olhou para mim se filho o
que eu tenho para te dar é benção muita
oração e intervenção ela muita coisa eu
já tinha o que começar eu peguei a uma
sandália eu coloquei na mochila coloquei
uma camiseta duas bermudas uma tia minha
ele deu uns trocados e de madrugada eu
entrei na carreta foi para goiânia
o dever dois dias para chegar lá o meu
amigo pagava o lanche na estrada por um
momento de bastante a passava muito
ciúmes na minha cabeça mas eu tava muito
determinado e cheia de esperança de que
minha vida e a melhorar eu tinha
esperança e eu ia lutar para que aquilo
o das
e como lápis em torno da mão e me dou
uma luva e se faço chover com dois
riscos eu tenho um guarda-chuva em
goiânia nem tudo foram flores mas eu
começava a dar por aquela capital e via
vários edifícios eu não via dificuldades
eu vi a oportunidades eu vi a muitas
coisas boas que aconteceu comigo em
algum momento mas que eu não pudesse eu
não não poderia desistir e sim continuar
aquela caminhada então eu me engajei no
grupo de jovens e sem condições mas eles
me deram colchão eles me deram uma
bíblia e a dona de um lote lá tinham um
quartinho e me emprestou esse quarto ela
exigiu quando você começar a trabalhar
você paga ele para mim eu vi que você tá
querendo começar e tá aqui e assim eu
comecei explorando todas as
possibilidades que estavam à minha
disposição e foi assim a minha vida em
goiânia no começo foi bastante tem
é mas eu enfrentei eu perguntei o
desafio e nesse mesmo quarto eu estudava
para o vestibular eu viajava voltava no
final do dia comi muito pão de sal com
com leite no supermercado porque
realmente não tinha a grana para pagar a
marmita mas mesmo assim isso não me
desmotivava pelo contrário acredito que
esse foi o combustível muito forte para
que o gás e outros voos
o e passei no vestibular faculdade
anápolis eu viajava todos os dias foram
cinco anos da minha vida de goiânia à
anápolis eu saía do trabalho pegava dois
blusões até a br para poder pegar o
ônibus que realmente fato ia para
anápolis foram cinco anos essa jornada
era difícil não talvez para alguns para
mim que já tinha vindo de um mais 7 de
tantas coisas que tinha passado na minha
vida na minha infância aquilo era mais
uma provação era mais uma era mais um
gás que eu tinha que dar para mim era
mais um prêmio que a vida tava me dando
para que eu pudesse conseguir os meus
objetivos e eu perguntei ainda assim
passei cinco anos para concluir a
faculdade e consegui
e numa folha qualquer eu desenho um
navio de partida com alguns bons amigos
bebendo de bem com a vida eu realmente
crescer de fato através das minhas
parcerias das minhas amizades dos meus
amigos as pessoas que estavam no meu e
touro é uma pessoas boas de coração é só
você que me ajudando com grana com
lanche com vale-transporte e me ajudou
de alguma forma porque ela tava vendo
meu esforço então muita gente ali se
mobilizava lá na cidade de goiânia para
me ajudar e aquilo me dava força para eu
não desistir e eu caminhei terminei a
faculdade consegui realmente para fazer
pós-graduação e logo depois eu sonhei
muito e fazer o mestrado esse mestrado
era um é um triunfo na minha vida e eu
queria só que quando eu entrei eu entrei
em belo horizonte eu já estava em montes
claros trabalhava a semana inteira
chegava deixava o carro da empresa na
quinta-feira de manhã pegava o ônibus
pegava carona
o avião já tá a situação já tava
melhorzinha e eu vinha para belo
horizonte passei muitas turbulências
financeiras mas eu também não desiste
porque que eu não desistirei
é porque o que realmente eu queria de
fato voar um pouco mais alto eu queria
ter uma condição melhor e tudo que tava
passando a minha vida eu sempre voltava
na minha infância para recrutar aquela
força e realmente me dá esse gás e
chegou o grande dia o dia de eu receber
esses diploma de mestre foi um dia muito
especial para mim mas antes de receber
esse diploma faltava 80 dias para que eu
recebi esse esse título defender
dissertação de fato a minha mãe faleceu
e eu fiquei sem chão e pensei em trancar
realmente fato mestrado mas eu lembrei
da força que aquela mulher tinha me
passado na infância para que eu não
desistisse das coisas eu não desisti
e eu fiquei realmente sem chão por
alguns dias recortei forças e fui
conseguir defender dissertação peguei o
diploma quinze dias depois eu recebi o
título de mestre a minha filha nasceu
foi um presente de deus então foram
muitas emoções que permearam a minha
vida a educação sempre esteve presente e
eu devo muito a isso a educação meus
próximos passos são e o doutorado e
pós-doutorado porque eu sei que agora eu
posso eu precisava estar eu precisava
começar e eu comecei e eu tenho certeza
que essa jornada não para mais
e sobre o futuro mesmo ele se der certo
é mas eu convido vocês a olhar não com
olhar de um adulto mas com a leveza ea
simplicidade de uma criança e digo mais
vinícius de moraes diz o seguinte mas
ele diz conhecia esse fato
extraordinário de que o operário faz a
coisa e a coisa faz o operário de forma
que certo dia a mesa ao cortar o pão o
operário foi tomado de uma súbita emoção
ao constatar assombrado que tudo naquela
mesa garrafa prato facão era ele quem os
fazia ele um humilde operário um
operário em construção muito obrigado tá
e aí